[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en poco su cita
con la actualidad francesa por las
pantallas de France 24 que realizamos
desde la ciudad de Niza en el sur de
Francia
[Música]
el 14 de julio del año 2016 en este
mismo paseo de los ingleses un camión
embistió a las miles de personas que
asistían al espectáculo pirotécnico de
la fiesta Nacional de Francia 86
personas fallecieron entre ellas 15
niños que hacían cola para comprar
caramelos seis años después Francia
juzga a 8 personas acusadas de haber
ayudado con dinero armas y a conseguir
el camión al autor del ataque que
también murió ese 14 de Julio después de
los procesos por los atentados del 13 de
noviembre en París y de saliendo Esta es
una nueva prueba para la justicia y la
sociedad francesa
desde el pasado 5 de septiembre el
Palacio de justicia de París vuelve a
estar bajo vigilancia esta vez para el
proceso por el atentado de Niza algunas
víctimas hacen el viaje desde la costa
azul como Celia Vial que perdió su madre
ese 14 de julio
ella no está aquí para defenderse mi
padre lo estaba pero fue herido en el
atentado para él sería muy duro yo me
siento con fuerzas para testimonial por
ella para explicar la persona que fue a
900 kilómetros en Niza muchas víctimas
lamentan que el proceso se realice en
París ellos pueden venir a esta sala
especialmente preparada para el
retransmisión de las audiencias en el
Palacio de eventos de la ciudad
Estoy estresada tengo el corazón
apretado evidentemente estoy sufriendo
pero yo esperaba este proceso con
impaciencia seis años después parecen
largos pero es el tiempo necesario para
estar fuerte para enfrentar este juicio
este proceso histórico que se extenderá
durante tres meses tiene un gran ausente
Mohamed la West Bullet el terrorista
abatido al volante de su camión la noche
del atentado ocho personas son juzgadas
por una corte especial y se sospecha que
al menos tres de ellas estaban al tanto
de su adhesión al yihadismo Aunque la
investigación no permitió determinar si
sabían de su proyecto de atentado como
el cliente de este abogado
él no sabía nada de lo que pasaba en la
cabeza de Mohamed del proyecto mortífero
que tramado ahí De hecho no participó de
ninguna manera
una explicación inaceptable para los
familiares de las víctimas ellos
ayudaron a realizar este atentado siendo
transportados en el camión visitando las
locaciones con contactos telefónicos
algunos incluso entregándole armas ellos
contribuyeron a la logística No tuvieron
un rol secundario casi 2000 personas se
han constituido en demanda civil está
previsto que declaren ante la Corte al
menos hasta el 21 de octubre solamente
entre los fallecidos había 38 con
nacionalidades ningún latinoamericano
estuvo entre las víctimas fatales sin
embargo Esteban un chileno forma parte
de los demandantes civiles Esta es su
historia
cada vez que puede Esteban este bailarín
y artista plástico chileno asiste a la
redifusión del juicio por el atentado de
Niza del 14 de Julio en el Palacio de
congresos de la ciudad puede ver en
directo lo que ocurre en las audiencias
de París
demandas civiles de este importante
proceso
creo que importante para las víctimas es
importante que puedan pasar después de
estos seis años
reconstruirse y encontrar soluciones no
quedarse en la duda que sean condenado
lo que deben ser condenados y y y crear
nuevos protocolos de la seguridad crear
protocolos para poder como atender a las
personas En caso que haya un acto
terrorismo
de que sean realmente protegidos
si Esteban le preocupa la protección es
porque ese 14 de Julio él se encontraba
en el Paseo de los ingleses se salvó del
camión pero no de las secuelas
psicológicas del atentado estuvo cuatro
años en terapia formado en primeros
auxilios debido a su trabajo en escuelas
decidió quedarse a ayudar a las víctimas
el camión pasó
al lado de nosotros y me fui
inmediatamente ayudar a las personas mi
amigo se fueron hacia atrás Es decir
corrieron hacia el otro lado de la playa
la gente escapó entonces quedó muy poca
gente que quedó a ayudar porque no
sabíamos si el camión iba a explotar no
sabíamos si había más terrorista se
habló que tal vez
hay personas que hay Rehenes entonces
había realmente Una
estábamos todos perdidos en foto no
sabíamos junto a otras víctimas Esteban
espera demandar al estado y la ciudad
por la escasa protección que había ese
14 de Julio Pese a que el país seguía en
alerta terrorista
el gato mientras su reconstrucción la
realiza a través del arte hace cinco
años participó en la creación del
documental de danza el soplo de la vida
que evoca ese 14 de Julio además hace
casi dos meses que trabaja en una gran
arpillera hecha de Telas e hilo yo
estaba como por aquí en ese sentido
entonces evocar este momento educar a
las personas que partieron pensar un
poco las personas que que se fueron
nadando pero en el fondo podemos ver que
hay color hay una parte negra pero en el
fondo esta idea de la vida una idea de
seguir viviendo de pensar un poco a la
vida y
y no quedarse tanto en esta idea de
lo que ocurrió Hace seis años
la obra La realiza junto a su pareja
Federica una vez finalizada esperando
donarla al museo Memorial del terrorismo
que debe abrir no lejos de París en 2027
en los últimos años Francia encadena los
juicios por los atentados yihadistas que
han tenido lugar en su territorio los
del batán y las Terrazas los atentados
contra jolieve o el supermercado judío
en vansen el atentado contra el padre
jacamel Degollado normandía en el
anonimato las asociaciones de apoyo a
las víctimas tienen un rol muy
importante en estos procedimientos
Sofía seco directora de la federación
Nacional de víctimas de atentados
terroristas Gracias por esta entrevista
con Francia 24 Sofía A qué situaciones
se está enfrentando su asociación en lo
que va de este juicio por el atentado
del 14 de julio del 2016 en misa ahora
acompañamos a las víctimas y familias de
las víctimas desde el 14 de Julio en la
noche y este proceso es el punto
esencial de un recorrido de
reconstrucción y en esta audiencia
tenemos distintas expectativas distintas
preocupaciones de parte de las víctimas
y sus familias si algunos necesitan
respuestas para reconstruirse otros no
quieren Escuchar hablar de lo que pasa
en Las audiencias porque creen que eso
podría abrir su herida y que no tienen
necesidad de saber más que lo que
vivieron y sus consecuencias a las que
están enfrentados a diarios son
suficientes para sentirse víctimas las
situaciones son muy diversas justamente
Cómo se preparan los miembros de su
asociación para hacer frente a un
proceso como este salud
es un largo proceso un largo camino
hacia la verdad y la preparación es
jurídica pero también humana porque un
proceso es una prueba que nos
enfrentamos a lo más doloroso que hemos
vivido y que hay que preparar a las
víctimas a esta realidad que es
necesaria para su reconstrucción porque
no tener un proceso es como dejar un
libro abierto porque nunca se cerrará es
no poder expresarse y nunca poder contar
lo que se vivió es un momento también
para que la persona pueda compartir con
la sociedad lo que es ser víctima y lo
que es ser golpeado por el terrorismo te
permitirá la sociedad entender como el
terrorismo le ha golpeado su vida por
siempre una preparación como dije humana
psicológica jurídica pero también
logística Porque mucha gente viene de
lejos del extranjero
muchas personas se preguntan si un
proceso como este es necesario sobre
todo porque las víctimas deben
enfrentarse a las situaciones dolorosas
que vivieron en este caso Hace seis años
los jueces
el proceso es una etapa difícil temida
pero necesaria para repro parte de su
propia historia que estalló en mil
pedazos la noche del 14 de Julio hay que
tomar la vida de una víctima como un
rompecabezas que explota
a través
y el juicio con las audiencias de los
investigadores expertos testigos va a
permitir responder algunas preguntas y
pegar los distintos Trozos de este
rompecabezas para enfrentar el futuro
con serenidad y tranquilidad el juicio
no ahorra nada nos sana pero permite
mirar el futuro teniendo el sentimiento
de haberse descargado de algo y de tener
las llaves para enfrentarlo con más
serenidad
un momento clave de lo que va de proceso
fue cuando se difundieron las imágenes
del paseo de los ingleses en Niza había
muchas víctimas que preferían no ver ese
vídeo en cambio otras personas decían
que lo necesitaban para reconstruirse
Cómo se explica eso al usoundtra
personal en una escala individual es una
elección muy personal por eso es
importante que el presidente de la corte
prevenga de la difusión para que cada
uno de acuerdo a sus dudas y su estado
mental pueda decidir si ver o no la
proyección nosotros como asociación
pensamos que a una escala colectiva es
un deber que tiene la justicia de
compartir ese video porque establece de
manera incontestable la verdad la forma
en como los hechos se desarrollaron esta
noche y permite a las víctimas
reconstruir ese momento donde todo
explotó ver al lado de quien estaban
como el camión les impactó o no donde se
fueron sus cercanos a quienes perdieron
entre la multitud y escala de la
sociedad permite fijar en la memoria
colectiva lo que fuese atentado del 14
de Julio
Sofía en este momento su asociación Está
al lado de las víctimas del 14 de julio
del año 2016 en Niza pero también lo
estuvo durante el proceso por los
atentados de París del año 2015 los
atentados en contra de relieve y el
supermercado judío de la puerta de Vans
en fin durante todos esos procesos que
tienen que ver con los atentados
yihadistas que sufrió Francia los
últimos años cómo están viviendo este
momento
es un momento clave de nuestra historia
judicial pero también de nuestra
historia en su sentido general porque
descubrimos como la justicia francesa
trata estos actos de terrorismo
contemporáneo los atentados de masas y
es algo esencial para entender estos
hechos permite Buscar las raíces de la
radicalización de las personas que
pasaron al acto y entender también Cuál
es el lugar de la víctima en nuestra
sociedad nuestra asociación lo sigue muy
de cerca intentando siempre estar del
lado de la víctima y acompañarlas en sus
preguntas y sus expectativas
Muchas gracias Sofía seco por esta
entrevista con Francia 24 Gracias
y hasta aquí este capítulo de Francia
enfoco que despedimos desde la plaza
macena de Niza Muchas gracias por su
compañía y hasta una próxima por la
pantallas de trans 24 o en France 24.com